اعاده تدوير بكل بساطه هو اعاده استخدام
المخلفات مصطلح غائب عن كثيرين عمليا لكن
الامريكيه سرسكود جربت ونجحت في تحقيق
ارباح اعلى من ما توقعت وفقا لموقع سايدر
تقول ساره ان دخلها نحو 90,000 دولار
سنويا الان اضافت 37000 دولار من جمع
القمامه وبيعها بدا الامر مع ساره وهي
عائده للمنزل فشهدت قمامه الجيران متراكمه
امام الصناديق وبها الكثير من الاثاث
جمعتهم وفي غضون 48 ساعه باعت كل شيء على
سوق فيسبوك وتوضح ان زوجها شريكه في
المشروع الجديد الذي لا يستغرق منهما سوى
خمسه ساعات اسبوعيا من حيث الجمع والتصوير
والعرض
اعاده التدوير هي التقاء البيئه مع
الاقتصاد من المتوقع ان يحقق هذا السوق ما
يصل الى 4.5 تريليون دولار امريكي بحلول
عام 2030 قدرت دراسه ان الدول مجلس
التعاون الخليجي وحدها يمكن ان توفر ما
يصل الى 138 مليار دولار بحر لعام 2030
بتطبيق النهج الدائري على اقتصادها
وبالنسبه للقطاعات لتكون البدايه بالاسهل
طبقا لاحصائيه فانا انتاج طن واحد من
مخلفات ورقيه سيوفر طاقه باربعه الاف ومئه
كيلو وات في الساعه كان 45% من استهلاك
الغابات في العالم لاذهبوا لي انتاج الورق
وبالنسبه لاعاده التدوير المخلفات معدله
يعتبر الصلب من المخلفات التي يمكن اعاده
تدويرها بالنسبه
لا نهائي من المرات اما تكاليف اعاده
تدوير الالمنيوم فانها تمثل 20% فقط من
تكاليف تصنيعه اما المواد البلاستيكيه
تقدر قيمه مخلفاتها الاقتصاديه باكثر من
120 مليار دولار امريكي سنويا ومن المتوقع
ان يصل حجم سوق اعاده تدويرها الى 900
مليار دولار في عام 2005